bonjour à tous après les samsung galaxy
à lui à 8 + galaxie f9 s9 plus il
pourrait y avoir il va y avoir mais on
va dire comme ça très prochainement des
galaxies a6 et a6 plus ses 100 ans
parlent maintenant
sainte sous continue à étoffer sa gamme
il faut toujours être présents parce que
toute façon la concurrence est là la
concurrence rapport je fais du côté de
chez apple
du côté de la chine aussi avec huawei au
pot honore tous ces fabricants de
smartphones qui ont des produits hyper
sexy et qui sont vraiment présents en
force et il leur faut toujours eu un
train avant pour passer c'est devant
c'est alors la gamme à on est sur le
moyen de gamme chez samsung
il ya déjà eu lieu à 8 qui est sorti en
début d'année qui r mon avis à mi chemin
entre les produits à 5 à 3 qu'on avait
sur les années précédentes et la gamme s
le18 est vraiment un excellent produit
et là on pourrait avoir on devrait avoir
des galaxies a6 et a6 plus alors à quoi
vont ressembler ces produits très
clairement on va rester un peu dans le
look du à 8 c'est à dire pour le 1 6 un
capteur photo simple à l'arrière pour le
assiste plus un double capteur photo
avec un lecteur d'empreintes digitales
positionner directement en dessous en
façade un écran un grand écran a priori
on pourrait avoir un d'écran infiniti
sur ce a6 et a6 plus ça pourrait être
carrément super sexy du point de vue de
la taille on aurait dû 5,6 pouces pour
le a6 et du 6 pouces pour le a6 plus je
vous lisez côté caméra on devrait avoir
cette fois ci par contre une 16
mégapixels à l'arrière et une 16
mégapixels en façade et double capteur à
l'arrière probablement 16 mégapixels et
16 mégapixels on imagine d'abord un tel
objectif pour aller chercher des choses
un petit peu lointaine dans l'image
pouvoir avoir un zoom optique
côté processeur on devrait retrouver un
exil aux 7870 couplé à 4 gigas de ram et
avec 32 gigas de stockage qui serait
bien sûr extensible pouvoir stocker plus
de vidéos plus de photos tous vos
souvenirs votre musique est plus tralala
côté patriote bravard de batterie de
3000 milliampères heures donc quelque
chose qui tourne aurait fondamentalement
bien alors que si on n'a pas plus
d'infos pas plus de fiches techniques
mais ce qu'on voit réellement c'est la
volonté de samsung d'aller toujours plus
faire une concurrence tout six
constructeurs chinois parce que là on en
prend au hasard par exemple owen plus
fait beaucoup parler de lui avec son one
piece si ce qui va être annoncé d'ici
très peu de temps et qui s'anime d'être
vraiment hyper cool et hyper sexy pour
ne pas perdre des parts de marché qui
sont grignoter un peu de toute part même
si effectivement pour l'instant samsung
a quand même une position assez
confortable
on va pas se mentir mais
malgré tout derrière ça pousse ça pousse
de tous les côtés les consommateurs sont
de plus en plus réceptifs à aller sur
des produits chinois xiaomi devrait
arriver en france aussi très très
prochainement avec des produits ils sont
vraiment super bien s'ils veulent pas
voir les parts de marché c'est à
grignoter et eux perdre au niveau de
leur position ils sont obligés de
répondre réponse fortement avec des
produits toujours plus cool toujours
plus sexy et surtout pas trop cher un
produit qui pourrait coûter entre 300 à
400 euros
forcément moins cher que les huit bien
évidemment mais par contre très bien
positionné par rapport aux produits
antérieurs de 2017 et 2016 alors à
savoir que le galaxy à 8 plus n'est pas
sorti en france il est disponible dans
d'autres pays donc il serait
complètement possible également qu'il ne
sorte en france qu'un samsung galaxy à 6
et que les assises plus on ne va jamais
arrivé dans l'hexagone donc ça
effectivement
c'est quelque chose à suivre aussi de
près je ne sais pas s'il ya intérêt
effectivement est ce que ça me saoule
sortent ces deux modèles un modèle en 6
pouces sur ce produit là je suis pas
convaincu est-ce que ça irait pas un
petit peu en concurrence par rapport aux
grands modèles us 9 ou du s fit plus le
sud plus on peut quand même trouvé un
tarif beaucoup plus intéressant
aujourd'hui
bon effectivement c'est pas le même prix
c'est pas la même chose mais est-ce
qu'un intérêt aujourd'hui avoir à 1,6
plus en france j'en suis pas convaincu
voilà un peu ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui effectivement sur ces
samsung galaxy a6 et a6 plus alors
restez connectés parce qu'on va en
parler très prochainement parce que vous
allez voir que samsung n'a pas fini de
nous surprendre alors on parle beaucoup
de samsung parce qu'effectivement il ya
des produits qui sont super cools le s9
ne plus parler d'eux sont vraiment des
produits sont vraiment top
on attend avec impatience l'arrivée du
galaxy fixe qu'il serait tarder à priori
peut-être pas cette année mais il
devrait arriver en 2019 alors je sais
que tous les ans on dit ça tous les ans
c'est la même chanson
mais rassurez-vous à un moment ou un
autre ils allaient finir par arriver
d'autant plus que la concurrence s'y est
mise également à développer des
smartphones des écrans pliables donc la
samsung va devoir
s'ils veulent être le premier sur le
marché va falloir un peu de ce coup 1
est ce que je veux dire boisé l'info
pour les a6 et a6 plus dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire est ce que
vous pensez que sur des produits milieu
de gamme vous pourriez vous laissez
tremper est ce que vous vous êtes laissé
tenter sur le a8 qui moi je trouve est
vraiment un excellent produit est ce que
ea 6 pourrait vous tentez entre les deux
est ce que votre coeur balance serait
plutôt d'un côté plutôt notre alors que
ce que ça peu prématuré doute
la question parce que le s y sont
énoncées pas énormément aujourd'hui de
ciudad quelques infos mais rassurez vous
restez connectés parce que dès qu'on
aura plus de nous est un portrait robot
un peu plus dessiner on va en reparler
d'ici là soyez sages portez vous bien
laissez-moi des jolies pouces abonnez
vous je vous embrasse pour les soirées
vous et à très bientôt
[Musique]